in other news a jury is convicted the
founder of a failed blood testing
company after a nearly four-month trial
and seven days of deliberations
elizabeth holmes told her investors that
her startup theranos could find
abnormalities in tiny blood samples that
was not true she was found guilty of
four counts of fraud and conspiracy the
jury found her not guilty of four other
counts and was not able to reach a
verdict on three more as consumer
investigative
correspondent rather anna warner reports
this is a big win for the government
a stoic elizabeth holmes held the hands
of her mother and husband as she left
the san jose federal courthouse monday
afternoon moments after the verdicts
were read she
did not seem to react at all reporter
emily saul has been covering the trial
for the podcast bad blood the final
chapter she just continued to sit you
know impeccably straight and listen
other than that there
there was no obvious reaction to the
verdict itself after they left she um
you know exchanged hugs with her family
holmes had been considered a visionary
who could change the biotech industry
with technology she claimed could test
for hundreds of health problems with
just a few drops of blood she left
stanford university at 19 to found her
company theranos in 2003. in 2015 she
spoke with nora o'donnell for cbs
mornings it sounds genius but what about
those who say that's not enough blood to
do all the tests that need to be done
especially if someone's very sick and
you're trying to figure out what it is
every time you create something new
there should be questions and
to me that's a sign that you've actually
done something that
is transformative
she was indicted in 2018. although she
was found not guilty on four charges
involving bogus test results for
patients and the jury deadlocked on
three additional counts they did find
she built investors out of their money
using false claims about the tech that
theranos had developed former prosecutor
michelle hagan says holmes likely sealed
her own fate with investor calls played
for the jury one of the investors
recorded the investment call where she
made these statements which turned out
to be false
so i think her own words incriminated
her
each count here comes with a potential
sentence of up to 20 years holmes of
course can appeal but the theranos legal
drama is not over next up sonny bowani
the former co of the company his own
trial is expected to start tony in
february
all right and a reminder we have tyler
schultz the initial whistleblower in the
theronos case coming up in our next half
hour anna thank you very much